if you like me you want to get that
feeling of playing for the first time
again now if you're watching Dark Souls
videos on YouTube you're probably fairly
good at the game and I bet you've
memorized all the enemy locations like I
have but when enemies are more
aggressive in this game they come from
different directions they come from
further away and you find them just
behaving differently in general these
new locations give that element of
surprise back to Dark Souls and you find
yourself being cautious again like you
were when you played this game for the
first time this is how you increase
difficulty in a game you get so many
hard modes and games including Dark
Souls where they just increase the
difficulty by increasing health and
damage of the enemies that's not a good
way to increase difficulty a good way to
increase difficulty is to change the AI
or to fundamentally change the enemies
you fight and that's why this is so fun
I play it up until the Lord vessel and I
had so many unique experiences and so
many unique deaths that I just have to
recommend this to you all so how do you
install this mod well it's a bit tricky
the version of the mod I found doesn't
work with the current version of Dark
Souls however it does work just fine
with an unpatched version of the game so
where do you download the unpatched game
well it's available on file sharing
websites please only get this if you've
already bought the game before and when
you download the mod a link will be in
the description if the mod has ever
updated to work with a current version
of Dark Souls I'll put an annotation on
the screen if you liked the way this
video was presented let me know it's a
style of presentation that you might see
a bit more often when I do playthroughs
of Dark Souls 2 I think I'd prefer to
show you guys highlights that have a bit
of creativity in them so anyway let me
know enjoy the rest of the video I had a
really good time with this mod
particularly in Anor Londo
enjoy